on a détaillé les spécialistes restent
prudents en france quatre formations
judiciaires ont été ouvertes contre x
aujourd'hui sur la gestion critiquée de
la criée du coc vide
un nouveau conseil de défense est prévue
ce jeudi à l'elysée
en france toujours le leader de la
france insoumise repart au combat jean
luc mélenchon a proposé sa candidature à
la présidentielle de 2000 22 à condition
de recueillir 150 mille parrainage
citoyen dont il se rapproche à vitesse
grand v avec ce soir pas de 130000 vote
si cette annonce est saluée par son
propre camp elle suscite moins
d'enthousiasmé auprès du parti
socialiste et chez les verts notamment
nous en parlerons avec alexis poulain
dans notre rubrique l'édito une semaine
après la présidentielle du 3 novembre
aux états unis donald trump continue
farouchement de crier victoire alors que
son rival démocrate joe biden va de
l'avant comme si rien n'était il dévoile
les membres de son comité consultatif
chargé de présenter le plan pour le pays
dès son investiture le 20 janvier
joe biden s'est aussi entretenu au
téléphone tout à l'heure pour la
première fois avec emmanuel macron qui
l'a félicité
c'est un communiqué qui a fait l'effet
d'une bombe alors que le nombre de décès
liés aux copies 19 ne cesse de grimper
les laboratoires pfizer et billons tech
font naître de nouveaux espoirs dans les
luttes contre le coc vide
il énonce que les essais sur leur vaccin
contre le virus sont très concluants
mais plusieurs questions restent en
suspens le point avec estelle farges un
vaccin efficace à 90% contre le coc vide
19 c'est ce qu'annonce l'américain
pfizer et son partenaire allemand
biotech dans un communiqué conjoint
diffusé ce lundi
aujourd'hui est un grand jour pour la
science et l'humanité
le premier ensemble des résultats de
notre essai de vaccin covit 10,9 de
phase iii fourni la preuve initial de la
capacité de notre vaccin à prévenir
locaux vides 19
la première analyse intermédiaire de la
phase 3 de notre étude mondiale fournit
la preuve qu'un vaccin peut prévenir
efficacement le coc vite 19
c'est une victoire pour l'innovation la
science est un effort collaboratif
mondiale cette fameuse phase iii a
débuté le 27 juillet dernier 40 3538
personnes y ont participé
sur ces individus un groupe a reçu le
vrai vaccins l'autre s'est vu inoculer
un placebo pour mesurer ce taux
d'efficacité à 90% les deux laboratoires
ont comparé le nombre de participants
infectés par le copie de 19 dans les
deux groupes
ils en ont donc conclu que les personnes
ayant reçu le vrai vaccins ont 90 % de
risques en moins d'être contaminés une
bonne nouvelle donc mais qu'il faut tout
de même relativiser
premièrement le vaccin des deux
laboratoires se base sur une technologie
appelée arn messenger totalement
nouvelle celle ci n'a à ce jour pas
encore fait ses preuves
deuxièmement les essais cliniques sont
toujours en cours et les résultats n'ont
été publiés dans aucune revue
scientifique comme l'indiquent ce
virologue chez nos confrères de marianne
ces résultats sont donnés par le biais
d'un communiqué de presse et non via un
rapport scientifique il est difficile de
tirer des conclusions
nous manquons par exemple cruellement
d'informations sur ce qu'ils entendent
par protection cela concerne-t-il tous
les types de malade qu'aggraver cas plus
léger quelle tranche d'âge sont
concernées par cette protection
comment l'immunité
évolue-t-elle dans le temps les
personnes immunisées sont-elles
vectrices du virus beaucoup de questions
restent en suspens si bon nombre
d'organisations salue ces nouvelles
encourageantes la prudence est tout de
même de mise au sein de la communauté
scientifique
exemple avec ce tweet vaccin files
heures les questions en suspens confirmé
les premiers résultats
combien de temps dure l'immunité quels
sont les effets secondaires les formes
sévères sont elles aussi éviter les plus
fragiles sont il est immunisée on reste
prudent même si l'espoir est là malgré
tout de nombreux pays ont déjà conclu
des accords avec les deux laboratoires
ou sont en passe de le faire c'est le
cas des etats-unis du canada du japon ou
encore de l'union européenne la france
elle fait savoir par la voix du porte
parole du gouvernement qu'il est trop
tôt pour décider des conditions de
déploiement du vaccin dans le pays de
leur côté files heures et bio ntech ont
pour objectif de fournir jusqu'à 100
millions de doses dans le monde d'ici à
la fin de l'année et 1,3 milliard de
plus en 2021 et vous l'aurez compris des
questions subsistent donc c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire pour en parler nous
sommes avec laurent alexandre essayiste
et chirurgiens bonsoir laurent alexandre
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés pour
en débattre frédéric bizarre économiste
de la santé bonsoir à vous aussi
frédéric bizarre merci d'être avec nous
alors je me tourne tout d'abord vers
vous docteur pour commencer avec
évidemment cette annonce spectaculaire
avec 5 qui serait fiable à 90%
on les entend déjà les critiques car
notamment sur la fiabilité des données
scientifiques
qu'est ce qu'ils en aient vous quel a
été votre réaction en ces résultats sont
encourageants mais c'est la première
fois qu'on a des résultats sur un vaccin
alors ce ne sont pas des résultats
définitifs pour l'instant il n'y a pas
suffisamment de recul on manque encore
de quelques semaines deux semaines de
recul pour pouvoir trancher donc l'essai
clinique manque à ce stade de puissance
statistique ce sont des résultats
intermédiaires comme le président de
pfizer l'a très bien expliqué lors de sa
conférence de presse de son communiqué
cela dit ce sont quand même des
résultats encourageants il faut les
confirmés et puis je partage tout à fait
le point de vue de mon collègue gilbert
de rennes
dans ses interrogations quelle est la
durée de la protection est ce que les
formes graves sont aussi protégés éviter
et puis aussi un point très important
les malades qui évite la maladie en fait
les patients potentiels qui évite la
maladie grâce au vaccin
est-ce qu'ils sont seulement protégé e
où est-ce qu'ils sont aussi il évite
aussi de contaminer les autres
autrement dit est-ce que le vaccin et
stérilisant c'est-à-dire qu'ils
protègent les individus et en plus ils
évitent la transmission vers d'autres
malades donc toutes ces questions se
posent
elles vont doivent d'être tranchée dans
les semaines qui viennent
de toute façon nous ne disposerons pas
massivement du vaccin avant s'est vrillé
mars parce que les délais de fabrication
et de diffusion sont longs il ne faut il
ne faut pas oublier que ce vaccin est
une première c'est un vaccin arn et la
rn et fragile donc il va falloir
conserver le vaccin entre moins 70 c'est
moins 80 degrés donc la diffusion la
distribution de vaccins ne va pas
pouvoir se faire comme d'habitude par
les médecins et par l'est et par les
pharmaciens dans certains pays il va
falloir une distribution centralisée
il n'y a que les centres de recherche
les hôpitaux et les cliniques qui
dispose de frigidaire à -70 ça moins 80
degrés qui vont pouvoir conserver le
virus et donc le distribuer et lino culé
aux patients dans l'hypothèse que tout
le monde espère ou ce vaccin sera
effectivement efficace comme les données
préliminaires d'hier semblent le montrer
frédéric bizarre on l'a entendu
également confirmation de la bouche de
laurent alexandre qui connaît bien le
sujet encore beaucoup de deux questions
des essais qui ne sont pas totalement
terminé des études scientifiques qui
pour le moment
voilà donc pas suivi c'est un communiqué
de la part des laboratoires qu'on croit
finalement sur parole c'était normal
d'en parler dès maintenant selon vous on
peut se poser la question pourquoi est
ce que pfizer se précipitent un petit
peu avant le
l'obtention des résultats définitifs
pourraient en dire un mot tout à l'heure
cela dit je partage et on peut saluer le
succès on devrait dire sur le plan
technologique c'est une avancée
scientifique majeure c'est une nouvelle
forme de vaccin arn messagers on n'a
jamais eu jusqu'à maintenant avec ce 1
er m message est donc à partir de
biotechnologie du génie génétique à
rester accès plus la même façon de
fabriquer un vaccin et c'est d'ailleurs
le succès de la biotechnologie au
général rapport aux grandes big pharma
s'est pas le succès des big pharma s'est
fixé des jeunes sociétés des jeunes
pousses de biotechnologie puisqu'on voit
bio wintek on voit curva convoi moderna
sait aujourd'hui qu'ils sont sur le
devant la scène c'est pas sanofi s'est
par ailleurs c'est pas faiseur n'est que
le distributeur dans cette affaire là
donc ça c'est quelque chose quand même
qui est intéressant et qui monte quand
même qu'on est en train de changer d'air
y compris pour la vaccination donc ça à
mon avis et c'est une c'est ce qu'il ya
d'important dans cette nouvelle même si
on verra on n'est pas capable
aujourd'hui d'évaluer avec les données
qui ont été présentés véritablement la
force de la protection qui est apportée
mais je pense qu'on peut saluer ce
succès là maintenant pourquoi est-ce que
freezer un petit peu se précipitent
c'est parce que c'est une course c'est
une course contre la montre mais c'est
une course entre les laboratoires c'est
à dire qu on est ce qu'on va essayer de
stimuler un maximum de près comment on a
toutes les précommandes qui on est et
qui auront été conclu ça ne sera pas
conclue avec les autres on prend de
l'avancé par rapport à ça maintenant il
faut savoir qu'il ya des facteurs
limitants absolument essentiel et je
pense que ça ne changera rien pour au
moins les six mois voire l'année de kiki
qui est devant nous tant pour la france
pour des questions de limitation de
production pour des cons c'est qu'il ya
des des composantes notamment des
enzymes laurent alexandre connaissez
mieux que moi pour produire ces vagues
salah ou qui font que le 1 milliard 300
millions de doses qui est annoncé me
paraît difficile dit difficilement
crédible on sait qu'il faut construire
ses usines de production il ya très peu
aujourd'hui qui existent vous pouvez pas
transformer des usines qui fabriquent
aujourd'hui des vaccins dénommé russe en
deux usines en tout cas vous pouvez pas
le faire du jour
demain donc tout ça va entraîner d'été
laich qui font que probablement il va
falloir attendre de fin 2021 mais ce qui
n'empêche que avec l'hypothèse que ce
vaccin soit efficace de façon suffisante
c'est un arsenal qui se remplit par
rapport à ce qu vide et qui devrait nous
aider à aller vers cette immunité de
groupe puisqu'on voit que
malheureusement ce virus est là pour
durer dans notre environnement
donc il va falloir ramener de la femme
des populations doivent cette immunité
de groupe et ça sera une arme
probablement très intéressante à moyen
qu'un laurent alexandre a justement
parlé de ces doses par milliards
certainement nécessaire l'union
européenne qui d'ores et déjà on le sait
va signer 300 millions de doses ont pré
commande
alors qu'on a toujours ces questions
dont on parle depuis le début de ce
débat en suspens pourquoi autant de
confiance parce que ce sont les états
unis l'allemagne
c'est sur parole finalement on aura
cette efficacité ou les études on était
quand même suffisamment sérieuse on a on
n'a pas le choix
le confinement les gens n'en veulent
plus aucun médicament antiviral n'a fait
la preuve de son efficacité l'hydroxyde
chloroquine ne marche pas le rem désir
ne marche pas l'interféron ne marche pas
le petit navire ne marchait pas donc
aucun des quatre groupes d'antiviraux
qu'on a testé le fonctionnent donc on
n'a pas de médicaments
certes la réanimation donne de pas trop
mauvais résultats et la mortalité des
gens qui ont des copies de grave a été
divisé par deux depuis le printemps mais
on n'a toujours pas de traitement donc
nous sommes bien obligés de croire dans
le vaccin est et en plus on ne voit pas
arriver de médicaments antiviraux dans
les 12 à 18 mois qui viennent donc la
seule carte qu'on a à jouer
à moins d'avoir une récession mondiale
grave et bien ou agra à cause d'un
confinement généralisée que les
populations ne vont plus supporter la
seule carte qu'on peut jouer c'est le
vaccin il ya une dizaine de vaccins à
l'heure actuelle qui sont en phase iii
celui de pfizer et le plus avancé
les données sont intéressantes mais
elles doivent être confirmées
alors il est peu probable que le
président de pfizer et menti pour une
raison très simple c'est que le gendarme
de la bourse aux états unis et d'une
sévérité extraordinaire et donc la sca
qui vérifie la véracité des déclarations
des entreprises cotées à la bourse de
new york
eh bien elle ne laisserait pas passer
une fausse déclaration
car une fausse déclaration une
déclaration trop optimistes du président
de pfizer hier serait en réalité une
manipulation de cours et le gendarme
boursier américain sanctionne ça de
façon dramatiquement méchante
alors effectivement justement vont
passer très bien le plat long alexandre
fisc américain blizzard l'économiste que
vous êtes ça ne vous a pas échappé ses
actions ce a donné le sourire à la
bourse des actions notamment d'air
france de renault et les compagnies qui
pâtissent beaucoup de cette crise sont
remontés comme par enchantement quel est
le constat de l'économie il ya beaucoup
évidemment de d'argent en jeu bien
évidemment autour d'un vaccin comme ça
je suis pas sûr que rolf schnyder ne
fait pas des révélations comme ça à la à
l'emporte-pièce et autres c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement sérieux maintenant
files heures si vous regardez bien un
petit peu ce communiqué de presse qui
est relativement court divulguer des
informations qui nous permettent pas
d'en savoir énormément et de tirer des
conclusions
on ne sait pas exactement sur quelle
tranche d'âge c'est efficace on ne
connaît pas la nature de la protection
je crois que gilbert de rennes hôtel en
sweat bon donc
donc il ne ment pas simplement il nous
donne juste une bribe d'information pour
nous dire c'est probablement que ça va
marcher mais est-ce que ça va marcher
dans des proportions importantes ou dans
des proportions relativement faible 90 %
est à prendre
c'est un chiffre très élevé et un ça qui
est vraiment le bon truc mais mais mais
on peut pas en tirer des conclusions sur
la la force de la protection définitive
ruia voilà on va pas entrer dans le
détail mais ça je pense que ces matches
pourquoi est-ce que files heures le fait
encore une fois c'est parce qu'il ya des
parts de marché à prendre parce qu'il va
avoir des concurrents sur la même
technologie et donc il ya des parts de
marché à prendre le plus tôt possible à
partir du moment où vous avez signé des
pré commandes avec les états avec
l'union européenne avec les états unis
vous avez pris ses parts de marché avant
les les concurrents bon donc c'est une
face ça me paraît une logique assez
assez naturel vous pouvez passer un
certain nombre d'accords plus tôt que
les autres
je crois que d'une tech a passé des
accords avec ressoude en chine donc vous
pouvez accélérer un peu le développement
du business plus rapidement que les
autres qui attendent leurs résultats
vont pouvoir passer à cette phase de
développement
c'est assez naturel il ya il n'y a rien
de des extrêmement choquant faut juste
pas trop naïf par rapport à ce qui se
passe et c'est un as et un effet
collatéral
d'abord on est un peu dans une
exubérance irrationnelle de la bourse
qui a un sens et des valeurs liées au
tourisme
alors que franchement le tourisme
risquent pas de reprendre avant 2022 ait
compris avec la sortie de ce vaccin bon
mais c'est comme ça c'est la logique de
greenspan sur l'exubérance de la bourse
en tout cas le pas parole du
gouvernement reste lui aussi prudent et
j'ai trop peur j'imagine que les les
français voilà en tire des conclusions
un peu trop hâtif peut-être je me
propose d'écouter gabriela talent c'est
toujours encourageant mais qu'il faut
être d'une très grande prudence
dès lors que les données scientifiques
ne sont pas connus dès lors que
l'ensemble des essais et des tests n'ont
pas été réalisés il faut être
extrêmement transparent aussi devant les
français pour leur dire que le vaccin ne
pourra pas être une solution à la
deuxième vague que nous vivons c'est
important de le rappeler et de le dire
de la prudence a quand même un laurent
alexandre de la part du porte parole de
gouvernement alors on parle quand même
de tester ou de vacciner toute la
population d'ailleurs le vert 1 yannick
jadot veut lui déjà rendre obligatoire
ce vaccin votre sentiment là-dessus
est-ce qu'on a les moyens les structures
et puis aussi qui va payer en trouvant
la même chose alors le vaccin sera
remboursé par la sécurité sociale à à
100% donc je ne me fais mais la vrai nom
il est payé franchement pas très cher
par rapport à ce que coûte une journée
en réanimation quand les gens font écho
villegats aggrave le vaccin est vraiment
pas cher du tout la question qui va se
poser c qui faut-il vacciner
est-ce qu'il faut vacciner uniquement
les 25 millions de personnes âgées de
baisse de diabétiques et de malades
présentant une pathologie à ceux ci
risque grave qui risque de faire un kobe
grave ou est-ce qu'il faut vacciner plus
largement personnellement compte tenu de
la très faible mortalité chez les jeunes
et même si les jeunes peuvent
transmettre le virus je serais plutôt
partisan de vacciner 20 à 25 millions de
personnes âgées de personnes à risque je
ne suis pas favorable à une
généralisation est une obligation
vaccinale chez les moins de 60 ans
frédéric bizarre on va terminer avec un
sondage ipsos sur justement le
scepticisme de certains français on
connaît le sujet parker sur les vaccins
regardez sur dix-huit mille personnes
interrogées dans 15 pays 73% sont prêts
à se faire vacciner en france mans 54 %
des sondés souhaitent
se soumettre à ce vaccin le plus bas du
classement il ya toujours ce scepticisme
frédéric bizarre ça vous étonne non
parce qu on connait enfin franchement
quand on voit ce qui reste des libertés
de ce qu'on fait des libertés
individuelles de la responsabilité
individuelle dans ce pays
avec ce confinement ce genre de
déclaration est d'abord une
méconnaissance complète de la santé
publique la santé publique n'a pas
vocation à être liberticide
la santé publique est faite sur de la
sueur de l'éducation sur de la pédagogie
sur de l'incitation
nous sommes le seul pays au monde avec
l'italie mais qui a arrêté à rendre
obligatoire dans les pays démocratiques
j'entends à rendre obligatoire la
vaccination depuis deux ans tellement on
a échoué en matière de santé publique la
france a organisé la santé autour des
individus il faut maintenant qu'elle
organise autour de la population il faut
passer du soin à la santé publique
c'est une évolution de notre système
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre plutôt
que de faire des déclarations et je suis
d'accord avec laurent alexandre il va
falloir cible est probablement une
population est bien plus à risque et le
faire sur une base d'incitation enfin
chacun aura évidemment compris qu'il a
plutôt intérêt à protéger à protéger
l'autre pourquoi les français seraient
moins enclins à protéger les autres
périodes d'épidémie
c'est tout simplement savait plus vous
contraignez c'est la meilleure façon de
favoriser les campagnes anti vaccins si
vous commencez à contraindre est obligé
les gens vont se dire où l'art il doit y
avoir un loup parce que si on n'est pas
capable de m'expliquer pourquoi par moi
même avec mon intelligence je dois
réaliser une démarche c'est que
probablement il doit y avoir un risque
dans cette démarche alors qu'il n'y en a
quasiment pas laurent alexandre le mois
de la fin sur cette défiance des
français envers le vaccin c'est tout
simplement une défiance envers les
pouvoirs publics auxquels ils ne font
peut-être prince est juste et c'est très
étrange
la france le pays de pasteur le pays qui
a beaucoup développé les vaccins à la
fin du 19e siècle est le pays le plus
sceptique vis-à-vis des vaccins et 7 en
france d'ailleurs qu'il y a le plus fort
courant complotistes anti vaccins
donc là il ya une réflexion collective
qu'on doit avoir pourquoi la france qui
était un pays scientifique
extraordinaire est en train de devenir
un pays technophobes anti-science anti
technologies
anti-vaccins personnellement et c'est un
sujet connexe ça ne concerne pas les
vaccins j'ai été bouleversé par le fait
en savants comme cédric villani soit
devenue maintenant en titillant c'est
s'oppose à la 5g avec des arguments
absolument incompréhensible notre place
politiques favorisent cette défiance des
français vis à vis de la science et on
le voit au travers de la 5 v il est
aujourd'hui et est bannie par beaucoup
d'hommes politiques qui considèrent
qu'elle est nocive et on est le seul
pays au monde où il ya un courant de
défiance le contre la technologie sein
de ge est donc ça n'est pas spécifique
aux vaccins la france est en train de
devenir un paradis pour les
obscurantistes et un enfer pour les gens
qui aiment la science et la rationalité
merci beaucoup laurent alexandre
essayiste et chirurgiens merci également
à vous frédéric bizarre économiste de la
santé merci à tous les deux malgré un
renforcement du protocole sanitaire dans
les lycées pour enrayer l'épidémie de
kobe 19 plusieurs syndicats
d'enseignants ont maintenu leur appel à
la grève aujourd'hui
ils demandent les mêmes mesures dans les
collèges selon les chiffres du ministère
ont vendu plus de 8% de grévistes dans
le primaire un peu plus de 10 % dans le
secondaire et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct avec jean françois
guay professeur en lycée secrétaire fsu
ile-de-france 1 c'est le premier
syndicat de l'enseignement bonsoir jean
françois guay merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france 8 % de
participation à cette grève ça veut dire
que tout le monde ne vous a pas suivi on
n'a pas du tout les mêmes chiffres mais
aujourd'hui sont de 20% dans le premier
degré de 45 % dans le second degré à la
manière de compter du ministère est
quand même un peu spéciale puisque elle
inclut les congés elle inclut les gens
qui ne travaillent pas ce jour là on n'a
pas du tout les mêmes éléments en termes
de chiffres alors c'est vrai que dans le
premier degré ça peut-être été moins
fort mais on s'y attendait un petit peu
puisque
la grève s'est décidée un petit peu
tardivement et qu'il ya des déclarations
d'intention à faire dans les collèges
c'est plutôt une bonne surprise
ce qui montre bien l'inquiétude alors
par ailleurs dans les lycées c'est
encore un autre problème ça fait déjà
une semaine que certains établissements
se battent la semaine dernière se battre
pour obtenir des protocoles sanitaires
donc c'est vrai que ça a été un peu
compliqué après souvent des droits de
retrait des mobilisations des grèves de
se remettre là aujourd'hui en grève mais
nous on trouve que c'est une bonne
accroche à un bon départ en termes de
mobilisation tout cas ça signifie réelle
inquiétude alors moi je pense qu'ils
vont ils vraiment pas oui oui oui tout à
fait c'est vrai que le protocole
sanitaire été renforcée dans les lycées
peut-être qu'on a du mal aussi à
comprendre vos revendications c'était
pas assez suffisant pour vous c'est
uniquement dans les lycées j'ai envie de
nous raconte ses jeux la majorité des
élèves selon cisco la risée dans les
collèges il est le premier degré donc là
c'est vraiment uniquement les lycées
donc notre première demande c'est que ça
soit généralisé mais je crois qu'il faut
repartir de ce que disent nous disent
les collègues et nous disent les
collègues
ce qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils veulent
surtout pas servir si l'on véhicule ou
un temps dernier c'est à dire perdre le
contact avec leurs élèves ce qu'ils
veulent ce qu'ils ont demandé depuis
longtemps c'est qu'on réfléchisse à un
protocole sanitaire qui permettent de
conserver des élèves de les voir
régulièrement
alors ça peut être la forme matin non
pas après midi groupe b avec deux mille
places à côté une demi classe de l'autre
ça peut être sous la forme d'une journée
pour 1 journée pour un autre demi groupe
d'une semaine sur deux mais en tout cas
ce qu'ils veulent c'est surtout pas
revivre ce qu'ils ont vécu par l'anc et
au printemps dernier où on a perdu
beaucoup d'élèves la tuer et surtout
dans les quartiers défavorisés où ils
sont souvent vous avez des problèmes de
connexion avec problème de nombre
d'ordinateurs dans les familles ça a été
vraiment très très difficile et ça les
personnes à l'épaule pas lourd mais jean
françois w
maison pardonnez moi que ça va être la
même chose parce que si la moitié des
élèves restent chez eux
voilà c'est peut-être encore moins
lisible peut-être encore en moins
gérable pour pour les parents et ils
rester chez eux tout le temps un premier
groupement là et ça va être l'idée c'est
de les voir très régulièrement gens
quand on voit un jour sur deux soit
l'après midi du matin mais en tout cas
les voir régulièrement pour leur
redonner du travail par les accompagner
et puis évidemment voir fait recours et
leur donner tous les éléments importants
de connaissances mais en tout cas le
confinement tel qu'il a été fait on
attend l'heure où l'entente un pourrait
comprendre trois puisqu'il s'est passé
ça les collègues n'en voulait pas et au
niveau de la fsu on l'a dénoncé très tôt
très tôt on m'a proposé au ministre de
préparer ce confinement il ya eu aucune
préparation en amont
je rappelle que des pays comme l'italie
des pays comme l'espagne sont quand même
pas des pays qui sont dans une serre qui
sont dans une situation souvent
économique beaucoup plus difficile que
nous on était capable d'embaucher des
milliers des dizaines de milliers
d'enseignants en amont pour préparer une
éventuelle seconde vague
aujourd'hui quel est le vrai point noir
le pire si j'ose dire dans le quotidien
des élèves la cantine par exemple la
cantine c'est très compliqué parce que
les locaux alors il faudrait reprendre
encore une fois le problème en amont
c'est que les locaux sont pas adaptés
pour ce confinement et ça on l'entend je
dire les cantines c'est des services on
peut faire à deux service peut-être
trois en étant un peu les horaires mais
donc les élèves sa masse à ses cantines
se retrouvent en situation ils peuvent
pas respecter les gestes dits barrière
la distanciation de social qu'il
faudrait oui les cantines c'est un vrai
vrai vrai souci et c'est vrai que d'être
sur une alternance je vois dans certains
établissements on est sur une alternance
le matin ou l'après midi ça permet
finalement de régler ce problème des
cantines ou pour ça c'est une bonne
solution
merci beaucoup jean françois guay
professeur au lycée secrétaire f -s une
île de france d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france
c'est avec nous dans quelques instants
avec nous serons avec eux
l'éditorialiste alexis et poulin nous
parlerons notamment de jean luc
mélenchon le leader de la france
insoumise qui propose sa candidature à
la présidentielle de 2000 22 une annonce
loin de faire l'unanimité et puis
direction les états unis ou le
secrétaire américain à la justice mais
pompéo a donné son feu non le ministère
de la justice tout simplement donné son
feu vert à l'ouverture d' enquête sur
d'éventuelles irrégularités lors de la
présidentielle
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut être défenseurs du
climat de la nature et des animaux et en
même temps aimait la chasse bien sûr
c'est avoir conscience justement des
populations de comment les gérer si
aujourd'hui on arrive à plus ou moins
trouver un équilibre entre la
l'urbanisation l'agriculture et puis les
espaces naturels c'est grâce à la chasse
grâce aux chasseurs
selon des ong la chasse et la cause de
disparition de certaines espèces j'ai
bien l'impression que les espèces sont
en grande partie conservée grâce à la
gestion des chasseurs aujourd'hui vous
avez 23 ans vous êtes une femme qu'est
ce que vous espérez apporter justement à
ce monde de la chasse si je peux aider
avec avec ce que je fais sur les réseaux
sociaux etc suffira à montrer un autre
aspect de la chasse et à donner envie à
certaines personnes de la découvrir
[Musique]
on
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi qui ait des candidats
y a pas d'alternative en sort du
technique il est clair que tout le monde
attend saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la ligue
parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est on
dirait qu'il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
l'euro numérique nous dit la bce
existerait donc parallèlement aux
espèces sans les remplacer
évidemment ils avancent masqués ils vont
pas vous dire dès le départ on fait ça
pour supprimer le cache la bonne et
c'est déjà numérique
d'autant que ces numérique c'est clair
que le papier-monnaie france est
condamnée à terme
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que fait la banque
centrale elle récupère le système
technologique et elle se l'approprient
elle si vous avez une patrimoine
aujourd'hui vous regardez avec anxiété
votre portefeuille qu'une des matins
c'est pas du tout cas pour votre compte
en banque
on nous ok sur votre bande ka
traditionnel ça s'inscrit dans un
mouvement qui est là depuis déjà
plusieurs années qui est d'avoir le plus
de renseignements de ce que vous faites
pour vous utilisez comme un produit
peut-être que c'est le le modèle dont on
rêve
nos dirigeants actuels
[Musique]
badar 30 merci nous rejoindre en direct
sur rt france la candidature de jean luc
mélenchon pour la présidentielle de 2000
22 se précise alors que le député de la
4e circonscription des bouches du rhône
avait déclaré qu'il ne souhaitait
recueillir 150 mille parrainage pour se
porter candidat il se rapproche peu à
peu du but avec près de 130 mille votes
ce soir le leader de la france insoumise
peut ainsi espérer se lancer dans une
troisième campagne présidentielle si
elle constitue une vraie candidature de
gauche pour certains notamment au sein
de son propre camp elle est loin de
faire l'unanimité la candidature de jean
luc mélenchon on en parle avec vous
alexis et poulain notre éditorialiste et
notre rubrique l'édito bonsoir alexis
poulain merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors ça y est mélenchon
déjà candidats oui jean luc mélenchon
s'est déclaré dimanche soir au jt d'une
grande chaîne nationale il est donc
candidat à la présidentielle alors ils
respectent ils les maîtres des horloges
de la france insoumise il respecte son
planning
et peu importe le contexte ou plutôt si
le contexte finalement c'est repolitiser
cette crise sanitaire dépasser la
critique de la gestion sanitaire du
gouvernement et commencer dès maintenant
une campagne qui va être une campagne
marathon de plus de 18 mois où il peut
s'imposer comme un leader de
l'opposition parce que jean luc
mélenchon il est connu c'est un nom
connu dans les cours de récréation
il a l'expérience des campagnes passées
et puis il a décidé pour créer un peu la
surprise de proposer avant
d'officialiser sa candidature un soutien
citoyen de 150 mille signatures sur une
plateforme en ligne
nous sommes pour qu'il a lancé dimanche
soir également
il devrait atteindre les 150 mille
signatures assez rapidement cette
semaine et c'est une idée qui l'a prise
à lionel jospin en son temps et puis
nicolas sarkozy candidat en 2000
vous qui avait promis de mettre cette
investiture citoyenne en place s'il
avait été élu en 2012
donc c'est voilà un candidat déclaré
avec des forces son nom l'expérience des
campagnes passées une base militante
solide et resserré autour de lui et puis
quelques faiblesses à savoir il est
justement connu parce que ça fait très
longtemps depuis mitterrand qu'il est en
politique
certains pensent qu'il y aurait
peut-être un dégagisme au sein de la
france insoumise
en tout cas le but de jean luc mélenchon
est clair se poser en candidats majeurs
de l'opposition de gauche est évidemment
et pourquoi pas rassembler mais là rien
n'est moins sûr alors justement à cette
candidature divise c'est la gauche
manifestement oui d'après olivier faur
du ps que je vous propose d'écouter
avant de vous faire réagir alexis la
gauche et les écologistes s'ils veulent
gagner ils ont besoin de se rassembler
et toutes celles et ceux qui par leur
aventure personnelle initiatives
individuelles par leurs ambitions
égoïstes et bien menaçants en fait tout
simplement cette ce rassemblement
possible
et derrière ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'il déroule le tapis rouge sous
les pieds des manuels maquis ou alors
c'est le début de la fracture bon c'est
la continuité c'est la continuité la
gauche rassemblée c'est une ancienne
c'est quelque chose dont on parle
beaucoup mais qu'on ne voit rarement
arrivé ça avait été le cas en 80 pour
françois mitterrand qui avait réussi à
rassembler les forces de gauche mais
aussi françois hollande en 2012 d'une
certaine façon élu grâce aux voix aussi
de cette gauche insoumise
quand il avait déclaré mon ennemi c'est
la finance là on commence à l'envers
c'est à dire que chaque candidat de
gauche olivier faure pour le parti
socialiste mais aussi chez eux élevé
avec yannick jadot aimerait rassembler
autour de sa personne autour de son camp
et puis ça prend du temps de rassembler
de travailler sur des idées et la
présidentielle se rapproche à grands pas
alors il est temps que chacun
effectivement clarifie les choses se
déclare ou non déclarent avec qui il
veut travailler
yannick jadot par exemple a dit que non
il ne saurai pas il ne s'associerait pas
avec jean luc mélenchon mais pour les
autres
que ce soit d'anciens éléphants du parti
socialistes comme arnaud montebourg
christiane taubira ségolène royal et des
femmes bien sûr parce qu'il y en aura
dans cette campagne mais aussi la jeune
garde de l'écologie au delà de yannick
jadot à certains maires de grenoble
eric piolle par exemple qui ne cache pas
ses ambitions nationales donc on voit
bien que derrière les annonces de cette
volonté de rassembler de faire une plate
forme programmatique commune bien ça va
prendre du temps parce que la gauche est
divisée et pour longtemps et puis encore
une fois que jean luc mélenchon il
l'avait compris et il a un temps
d'avancé parce que cette plate forme
programmatique
il l'a créée pour l'élection de 2017
c'est l'avenir en commun un programme
ouvert qui est mis à jour bien sûr pour
2022 hélas pour ce qui est du
rassemblement de la gauche écologiste et
sociale et socialistes bien il va
falloir créer tout cela et en 18 mois
la gageure est de taille et à droite
alors est-ce que c'est déjà la course
également alors à droite c'est la drôle
de campagne puisque françois baroin que
tout le monde attendait durant l'été les
rumeurs étaient persistantes lui a
décliné toutes velléités présidentielles
alors depuis sheller le plan est divisé
entre ceux qui veulent une primaire à
droite dont bruno retailleau qui est
président du groupe l air au sénat et
qui souhaitent défendre ses idées au
sein d'une primaire dlr un nouveau style
un pas la primaire de 2017 qui a laissé
des souvenirs amers et cette primaire
elle est inscrite dans les statuts des
républicains donc il faudrait
effectivement la tenir et puis il ya
certains cadres du parti qui
préféreraient une candidature naturelle
comme celle par exemple de xavier
bertrand président des hauts de france
et qui arriverait pour rassembler son
camp la droite la droite au sens large
et porter un nouveau programme pour 2022
donc là reste un débat en cours chez l
air et qui n'est pas encore réglé loin
de là et puis il ya les autres candidats
de droite plus classique qui se sont
déjà présentés il ya marine le pen
inquiet de toutes les campagnes et
évidemment nicolas dupont aignan debout
la france ceux là sont habitués aux
campagnes marathon et ils sont candidats
évidemment donc pour la droite comme
pour la gauche on voit bien que l'idée
de rassembler l'idée de candidature
unique ou l'idée de clarification est
encore loin
et la présidentielle est encore loin
évidemment 2022 c'est pas demain
ouais effectivement merci alexis poulain
aux états unis à présent une semaine
après le vote le scrutin américain est
toujours contestée par donald trump le
locataire de la maison blanche continue
d'évoquer des fraudes hier les
procureurs fédéraux ont reçu
l'autorisation de lancer des enquêtes
mais rien n'indique pour l'heure quelles
sont leurs chances d'aboutir
nous retrouvons notre reporter thomas
bonnet en direct de washington bonsoir
thomas alors qu'est ce que vous pouvez
nous dire justement sur cette enquête
et bien c'est une décision qui a été
saluée par donald trump lui même vous
l'avez dit ce lundi bill barre le
procureur général des etats-unis a donné
son feu vert pour le lancement d'
enquêtes par les procureurs fédéraux
dans son courrier qu'il leur a adressée
il explique que cela concerne les votes
ou le comptage des bulletins avant la
certification des élections dans leurs
juridictions écoutez un extrait de ce
courrier
de telles enquêtes peuvent être menées
s'il existe des allégations claire et
potentiellement crédible d'irrégularités
qui si elle était avérée pourrait
potentiellement avoir un impact sur le
résultat d'une élection fédérale dans un
état alors cette décision du procureur
général ne veut pas dire que des fraudes
ont été constatées ce sera aux
enquêteurs de déterminer d'ailleurs
d'une barre a ouvert a averti pardon que
l'ouverture des enquêtes devait reposer
sur des allégations sérieuses et en
aucun cas sur ce qu'il appelle des
réclamations spéculative fantaisistes ou
farfelues alors normalement le ministère
américain de la justice n'intervient pas
vraiment sur ce genre de dossier qui est
plutôt du ressort des états fédéraux
suite à cette annonce d'ailleurs le
responsable du service chargé des crimes
électoraux a annoncé sa démission et
puis ce lundi la porte parole de la
maison blanche a également tenu à point
point presse au cours duquel elle a
réaffirmé la volonté de l'équipe de
donald trump de poursuivre les
procédures juridiques
on écoute cette élection n'est pas
terminée loin de là la procédure pour
obtenir un décompte précis et honnête
des votes ne fait que commencer
nous nous battons pour les droits de
tous les américains qui veulent avoir
foi et confiance non seulement dans
cette élection mais aussi dans les
nombreuses élections à venir
wii one est loin des calculs est précis
et légal
nous voulons un maximum de clarté renom
jaloux un maximum de transparence
nous voulons que chaque vote légal soit
conquérir et nous voulons que chaque
vote illégal soit on peut noter que
cette prise de parole a été interrompu
par la chaîne fox news qui l'a
retransmettait en direct car ils ont
jugé que la porte parole de la maison
blanche divulguer de fausses accusations
infondées et ce manque de preuves c'est
souvent ce qui est reproché à l'équipe
donald trump car même si des
irrégularités peuvent être constatés à
une échelle locale
il est impossible pour l'heure d'établir
qu'une fraude a été organisée en dépit
des affirmations du camp républicain les
enquêtes vont devoir faire la lumière
sur un certain nombre de faits mais là
encore rien n'indique pour le moment que
cela puisse conduire à un retournement
de situation concernant lice
sue du scrutin de son côté joe biden ne
répond pas su à ces accusations et
préfère se consacrer à la lutte contre
la pandémie de covile 19 dont il a fait
sa priorité l'état pied d'oeuvre depuis
le début de la semaine et l'ancien
vice-président a déjà reçu des coups de
fil de la part de dirigeants
internationaux comme c'est le cas
d'emmanuel macron regarder cette
séquence
je voulais vraiment me féliciter et
féliciter kamala harris pour cette
élection
angela merkel a également félicité joe
biden ce mardi avec qui elle souhaite
avoir je cite une collaboration étroites
basées sur la confiance
merci thomas bonnet en direct de
washington et en reste précisément aux
états unis on continue de parler de
cette présidentielle dont le feuilleton
est loin d'être terminé nous sommes en
direct avec dave perkins analyse
politique en direct de houston
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
oui bonsoir des perkins bonjour pour
vous merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france à leurs dernières
informations en date ce soir qu'on nous
le chef de la diplomatie américaine mike
pompeo a refusé de reconnaître la
victoire du démocrate joe biden à la
présidentielle en promettant je cite une
transition en douceur vers un second
mandat de donald trump 7 promet une
bataille ardue on a le sentiment d'être
dans deux mondes parallèles qui ne vont
jamais se rejoindre le buteur du
gauchito gil non d'abord je souhaite
dire qu'il n'y a pas pour le moment deux
victoires de haydn il faut que toutes
choses arrivent en soi donald rancourt
reconnaît sa défaite est lui encore de
ce titre de président élu soit que le
collège électoral
un conseil de représentants à des cinq
ans est à votre écoute du rider ne
remporte ce vote
l'anglais ce vote aura lieu à la
mi-décembre à droite avant l'une ou
l'autre de ces choses gleeden n'est pas
le président élu
les élections ne sont pas terminés et
prétendre que c'est le cas c'est
prématuré et manipulateur à mon sens
alors prématuré manipulateur il
n'empêche que tout le monde
acte comme ça enfin pour ceux qui se
comportent comme tels finalement aux
états unis dans le camp démocrate mais
aussi chez nous en europe 1 puisque
comme nous l'expliqué thomas bonne et
emmanuel macron notre président français
a parlé à joe biden qui a aussi été
félicité une nouvelle fois par angela
merkel comment vous analyser cela avons
donc une fois de plus thomas crown exit
qui devient le président américain les
médias européens ne nécessite pas non
mais que ce ne sont pas non plus les
médias américains qui le décide
la décision est prise
soit lorsque l'opposition accepte la
défaite ce qui n'est pas le cas où
lorsque le collège électoral vote ce qui
arrivera notre 14e descendre l'une ou
l'autre de ces deux choses quel que soit
le comportement du monde quelque soit la
façon dont on traite reste à des
réductions elle n'est pas terminée
une beauté des choses doit arriver et ce
n'est pas le cas elle est démocrate vous
dirais qu'il vient suffisamment de voix
d'avancé pour qu'aucun recours
judiciaires de puisse porter leurs
fruits
quelle est votre réponse beaucoup de
preuves qu'il ya eu une fraude
électorale à une échelle massive la plus
massive de l'histoire des états unis
des milliers de bulletins de vote ont
été introduites en un des bureaux
électoraux milieu de l'année alors que
les clos des comptes étaient
interrompues et des boîtes de centaines
de milliers de bulletins ont été
introduits alors que les dépouilles
heures étaient rentrés chez eux la nuit
et on ne sait rien sur ses bulletins de
milliers de bulletins très près en
pennsylvanie indique simplement le le
candidat électorale à la présentielle
alors qu'il ya bien d'autres choix sur
le bulletin est seule elle eu le choix
de candidats pour la présence était
sélectionné c'est très étrange
et si l'on regarde les courbes de cette
élection
on voit une
ans de donald trump sur dubaï et à 3
heures du matin c'est joe bayonne qui
prend le dessus sur donald trump
il ya également des problèmes avec
dorian software une entreprise de
décompte des votes dont le président est
le mari et de nancy pelosi la chef de la
chambre des représentants et cette
entreprise a été prise à plusieurs
reprises alors qu'elle changeait des
votes pour les transformer en vote en
faveur de jo batteur il ya vraiment
beaucoup de preuves des témoins qui
explique sue des règles contraignantes
au niveau de la loi qu'ils ont été
forcés de tamponner des bulletins avec
une date antérieure afin qu'il soit
accepté et les services postaux des
états unis prendra des des cas de figure
où des responsables ont demandé à leurs
employés effectivement d'antidater des
bulletins
quelqu'un a posté une vidéo en ligne de
lui contant des votes et fera sans les
bulletins et les jetant à la poubelle
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de preuves est
rien il ne faut rien était espéré tout
théâtre et ordonné très facile à voir si
on veut le voir ce qu'il se passe quand
on aura compris que voilà vous vous êtes
militant bien évidemment républicain
les démocrates ne sont ronds évidemment
pas d'accord avec vous en tout cas il y
aura l'ouverture d'une enquête sur
d'éventuelles irrégularités on a eu le
feu vert du ministère de la justice
aujourd'hui rapidement puisque je
voulais aussi aborder un autre sujet
avec vous est ce que vous en attendez
beaucoup de de cette enquête publique
afin que la loi doit être déterminé et
appliqué et les participants d'autres
revenir à la loi et c'est très clair
dans la constitution des états unis qui
est contraignante pour les 50 états les
élections ne sont définis très
clairement de la dax de l'élection en
décembre à en novembre on a choisi cette
date parce que elle était favorable au
vote par exemple aux conditions de
déplacement nous que le jour du vote
c'est le second jeudi de novembre et
tout bulletins reçus ensuite est illégal
ne devraient pas être prises en compte
les états ne peuvent pas changer les
lois électorales si cela va à l'encontre
de la constitution des états unis
une fois que ces situations sont résolus
que l les lutins arrivé après le jour
des élections
alors je pense que donald trump a
remporté la victoire je pense qu'il a un
avantage alors autre objet du courroux
de donald trump le vaccin de pfizer
l'administration de tram qui voit son
propre succès est le fruit de son
engagement financier pas très content le
président américain a regardé son tweet
jsf des as et les démocrates ne
voulaient pas que je reçoive un vaccin
gagnant avant les élections alors il est
sorti cinq jours plus tard comme je lai
toujours dix contre onze cette
entreprise force est de constater pardon
pour la traduction différé force est de
constater qu'effectivement donald trump
avait annoncé ce vaccin pour novembre
ça avait suscité quelques grincements de
dents on comprend peut-être aujourd'hui
la colère de donald trump
n'est pas responsable de ce vaccin comme
le démocrate semblez le penser
il n'était pas dans un laboratoire en
train de manipuler les éprouvettes
il l'a dit est que grâce à
l'accélération du programme les vaccins
allaient arriver rapidement c'est le cas
mais il est très clair que pour des
raisons politiques
l'annoncé a été retardée jusqu'à ce que
les électeurs votent pour ou contre
d'une atteinte
donc ils sont au vert mais en fait de
politique simplement avec le moment où
ils sont publics c'est un lancement et
tous n'attendent pas tout à fait raison
d'être en colère je pense que c'est
cependant une petite chose qui n'a pas
beaucoup influencé le reste à des
élections mais effectivement cela rend
la chose pierre merci beaucoup dave
perkins d'alice politiques militants aux
républicains d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france opèreront fou le
parlement a voté hier la destitution du
président martin biscarrat le chef
d'état est accusé d'avoir reçu des pots
de vin quand il occupait le poste de
gouverneur un événement loin de faire
l'unanimité dans le pays pierre vis à
vis des incapacités moral sur fond
d'accusations de pots-de-vin voilà ce
que les parlementaires péruvien reproche
à martine vizcarra le pourtant très
populaire président qui donc
définitivement le palais gouvernemental
ce soir le parlement de la république à
voter pour les vacances de la présidence
comme je les dis à la fin de mon
discours ce matin l'histoire le peuple
du pérou jugeront les décisions de
chacun et j'ai fait le maximum d'efforts
pendant 45 minutes pour expliquer aux
130 parlementaires ce qui était le mieux
pour le pays
ils ne m'ont pas écouté et s'ils l'ont
fait ils ne m'ont pas compris
la seconde procédure de destitution en
moins de deux mois aura donc eu raison
du prix
résident péruvien pourtant devenu au fil
du temps le porte drapeau de la lutte
anti corruption
quelques minutes après l'annoncé de la
nouvelle à de nombreuses personnes se
sont rassemblées dans la rue pour
protester contre cette décision
parlementaire
les manifestants qui en veulent au
président de l'assemblée manuel mérino
ce qui se passe en ce moment est
horrible nous sommes avec les gens nous
détestons merino on ne veut pas le voir
même sur un tableau martin vizcarra doit
fermer le congrès pour que la démocratie
se poursuivent dans tout le pays
inacceptable c'est un manque total de
démocratie car c'est un pays
démocratique et les gens qui n'ont fait
ne pense pas au pays ils pensent à leurs
biens personnels
et c'est justement manuel mérino qui
prend les rênes du pays dès ce mardi
comme l'indiquent les reconstitutions le
beru va donc connaître un troisième
président en quatre ans signe donc d'une
fragilité constitutionnel dans le pays
un dans quelques instants
restez avec nous nous parlerons du
confinement et de la fermeture imposée
aux commerçants le hashtag artisans à
poil a vu le jour sur les réseaux
sociaux de nombreux artisans poser nue
pour alerter sur la situation de
détresse et puis nous évoquons le
glyphosate il ya trois ans emmanuel me
compromettez de l'interdire mais
aujourd'hui le président sont veut faire
machine arrière faute d'alternative
[Musique]
comment on peut expliquer qu'elle un
groupe énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables ce n'est pas explicable
mais ça permet d'envoyer aussi des
gratifications on va dire à des à des
politiciens nigérien la gestion
fantaisiste d'areva a des répercussions
incroyable jusqu'au président américain
obama donne son accord pour qu'areva
bénéficie d'un prêt de 2 milliards de
dollars alors que l'agent ce qui est
censé gérer ces prêts un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle crée un
incident
c'est pour l'éternité
[Musique]
où
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous parlerons de tout sans langue de
bois
[Musique]
à l'époque il y avait une concurrence
qui était assez violente d'ailleurs
entre les russes et les américains alors
que j'étais destinée à voler avec les
russes mais une opportunité s'est
ouverte de faire partie du deuxième
groupe d'astronautes européens qui m'a
envoyé aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa m'a entraîné qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs on est loin de la
guerre des étoiles en écho baigne dans
une espèce de con fraternité et de
solidarité l'exploration au sens large
est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout sans le fait en coopération
internationale malgré des tensions
à la surface de nos terres
[Musique]
certains disent que nous sommes pas une
chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous mêmes
nous parle de l'afrique comme d'un
continent en perpétuelle de vie son
dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à tout garder pour
les pays occidentaux ont favorisé cette
dérive en encourageant le maintien au
pouvoir de politiciens de plus en plus
âgés pour assurer la stabilité des pays
et des sous régions elles ont eu la
prétention de croire que les valeurs
qu'elle défend des est imposé par la
force dans leur conquête était universel
dans cette terre des possibles où
s'esquissent les figures du monde à
venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant co management à
l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu valable moi c'est fini pour moi
est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme son image art mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on peut être défenseurs du
climat de la nature et des animaux et en
même temps aimait la chasse bien sûr
c'est avoir conscience justement des
populations de comment les gérer si
aujourd'hui on arrive à plus ou moins
trouver un équilibre entre la
l'urbanisation l'agriculture
et puis dans les espaces naturels c'est
grâce à la chasse grâce aux chasseurs
selon des ong la chasse et la cause de
disparition de certaines espèces
j'ai bien l'impression que les espèces
sont en grande partie conservée grâce à
la gestion des chasseurs aujourd'hui
vous avez l'un trois ans vous êtes une
femme qu'est ce que vous espérez
apporter justement à ce monde de la
chasse si je peux aider avec avec ce que
je fais sur les réseaux sociaux expira a
montré un autre aspect de la chasse et à
donner envie à certaines personnes de la
découvrir
[Musique]
m
bonsoir à tous 21h heure française merci
de nous rejoindre pour cette deuxième
heure d'information tout de suite voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce mardi 10
novembre au lendemain de l'annoncé de
peur et biotech le fol espoir d'un
vaccin efficace à 90% contre le coc vide
mais de nombreuses questions qui
subsistent en l'absence de publication
détaillée les spécialistes restent
prudents en france deuxième semaine de
confinement si les chiffres frémissent
dans le bon sens la réouverture des
commerces essentiels ne sont pas encore
à l'ordre du jour
un nouveau conseil de défense se tiendra
jeudi à l'elysée
[Musique]
faux départ pour le glyphosate si
l'agencé nationale de sécurité sanitaire
restreint l'utilisation de l'herbicide
l'interdiction totale promise par
emmanuel macron devrait intervenir
finalement qu'en 2023
le gouvernement va débloquer une
enveloppe de 7 millions d'euros pour
accélérer la recherche sont les
alternatives selon le
knees l'agriculture ankara contrôlera
avec moscou l'application du cessez le
feu dans le haut-karabagh l'azerbaïdjan
se réjouit d'une capitulation d'arménie
évoque sa douleur l'accord a été signé
hier soir sous l'égide de la russie
des soldats russes seront déployés dans
la région dans le cadre du maintien de
la paix dès l'annoncé de l'arrêt des
hostilités
plusieurs milliers d'arméniens en colère
se sont rassemblés près du siège du
gouvernement arménien dans leur capital
alors la guerre est-elle vraiment finie
la paix est elle possible ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face au square
et maintenant emmanuel macron a reçu à
l'elysée le chancelier autrichien
sebastian course pour élaborer une
stratégie européenne contre l'islamisme
radical
l'autriche a été récemment touché par
une attaque une entrevue suivi d'une
visioconférence avec un gala merkel et
le président du conseil européen charles
michel président français appelle millet
une réponse rapide et coordonnée contre
le terrorisme
[Musique]
et on débute avec les derniers chiffres
du cor navires us en france santé
publique france dénombre 472 personnes
décédées à l'hôpital ces dernières 24
heures le même nom de patients admis en
réanimation a été également enregistré
plus de 40 4730 malades du coc 1019 sont
désormais en réanimation ou soins
intensifs et alors que le nombre de
décès liés aux covin ne cesse de grimper
les laboratoires pfizer est bio et des
cas font naître de nouveaux espoirs dans
cette lutte
il énonce que les essais sur leur vaccin
contre le coc vides sont très concluants
mais plusieurs questions demeurent en
suspens nos équipes sont allées demander
ce que les français pensent et de ses
vaccins déjà d'une part je trouve que ça
fait pas assez longtemps enfin pour
avoir un vaccin efficace je pense
on sait très bien qu'il faut des années
des années pour savoir si vraiment
quelque chose d'efficace et
personnellement je compte pas le faire
même si il est bientôt prêt je suis pas
pour les vaccins comme ça je préfère
laisser parler mon corps et faire voilà
qui se défendre tout seul tu préfères au
plus possible ne pas les fermer
si véritablement il y a un bon résultat
et vous n'a pas aucun souci avec
pourquoi pas je pense pas qu'on puisse
vacciner d'un seul coup il faut produire
les vaccins sont donc d'abord actionné
les sujets à risque parce que ça donne
mais ensuite on verra ça
oui mais j'attendrai je mangeais
attendrait les résultats de la situe
pasteur déjà elle compte parmi les
premières victimes du confinement
mécontents des aides accordées par le
gouvernement pendant leur confinement
des artisans et des commerçants de la
france entière pose nue et publié leurs
photos sur les réseaux sociaux sous le
hashtag artisans à poil l'initiative a
pour objectif de jeter un coup de
projecteur sur la situation économique
de leur commerce
déjà fragilisée par la première crise du
printemps dernier certains commerçants
ignore s'ils pourront rouvrir parmi eux
les salons beauté notamment pour en
parler nous sommes avec bérengère
pelletier godefroy esthéticienne au
poudrier de génie à evreux bonsoir
bérengère appel si godefroy merci d'être
avec nous et d'avoir accepté de
témoigner de votre situation sur rt
france pour commencer
justement quelle est votre situation
aujourd'hui l'envié on est fermé c'est
surtout pas quand est ce qu'on va
rouvrir et on a peur de ne pas pouvoir
faire noël et en attendant où on a les
factures qui tombe et on doit payer
alors entre eux un petit peu plus grand
de l'état le premier confinement vous
avez j'imagine été aidé par le
gouvernement expliquez-nous ce qui vous
pose le plus de problème finalement
aujourd'hui la trésorerie parce que mon
premier confinement on est obligé
d'attaquer notre trésorerie hélas son
gros confinement on y voir alors c'est à
dire que vous avez aidé été aidée lors
du premier confinement par le
gouvernement mais tout de même il
fallait que vous puisiez dans vos
réserves dans un second temps c'est bien
ça bat 1500 euros par mois c'est vrai
que c'est bien c'est déjà ça mais c'est
pas suffisant pour payer les loyers en
moi j'ai plus cher de loyer ça veut dire
que vous êtes combien dans votre salon
de beauté vous vous recevez vous êtes
salarié de ce salon et vous recevez 1500
euros en tout et pour tout c'est ça de
l'état lors de ces paroles de
confinement c'est le cas encore
aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est ça moi j'ai
une salariée et des apprentis et
aujourd'hui on est obligé d'avancer les
salaires quand même donc c'est toujours
de la trésorerie même si on va nous les
rembourser alors que pensez-vous de
cette initiative des artisans et des
commerçants de poser dans le plus simple
appareil et de publier sur les réseaux
sociaux est ce que pour vous cela peut
éveiller les consciences du gouvernement
notamment ben je trouve que c'est bien
ça mais belle image de ce qui nous
arrive on nous met à nu c'est à dire
qu'on est des premiers touchés je pense
que les normes sanitaires ont largement
été respectée dans tous les petits
commerces de proximité
que ce soit en esthétique en coiffure
importe le domaine je pense que tout le
monde a bien joué le jeu chez les petits
commerçants
et aujourd'hui c'est nous qui sommes
fermés et que c'est nous qui sommes
vraiment bagne au pied ni aux murs quoi
on attend les aigles donc on attend
début décembre mais en attendant le
début décembre
alors c'est vrai que le fait l'avocat du
diable mais mais j'imagine qu'à des
téléspectateurs voilà qui sont devant
leur télé qui se disent oui mais
malheureusement tout cela est très
malheureux notamment aussi pour les
d'ailleurs les restaurants les coiffeurs
on l'a dit mais c'est vrai dans
l'esthétisme on est en contact
voilà les trois forcément avec avec les
clients et ce qui a pas un danger
justement les clients le cren peut-être
mais aussi vos salariés alors
complètement il ya un danger les normes
sanitaires on est tellement élevé en
esthétique que je pense que on est
largement largement bord des changements
de vous
entre chaque cliente port du masque vie
hier on désinfecte à kevin entre chaque
cliente
moi personnellement il sonnait à la
porte des clientes sont accueillis au
coût de gouttes uniquement sur rendez
vous ce qui permet de gérer les kabyles
le binage tout donc je vois pas où est
le problème
justement comment on réagit
vos clientes et clients d'ailleurs
peut-être après le premier confinement
sont ils revenus dans l'est dans les
salons d'esthétisme où est-ce qu'ils ont
eu peur alors moi je sais pas si c'est
que chez moi mais moi les clientes sont
vraiment revenu et j'ai même gagné des
clients enfin gg c'est vrai que le mois
de mai a été très fort et même effet a
été très très très fort donc des
guillemets ça suffit pas après deux mois
de fermeture les clients plutôt
confiante finalement et peut-être qu'ils
aient envie de se détendre après un un
confinement
il ya un conseil de défense jeudi avec
une évaluation de la situation sanitaire
est ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement peut infléchir sa position
et annoncé la réouverture de de ces
commerces dits non essentiels alors je
pense que certains commerces devraient
rouvrir dont nous parce que notre
travail au rendez vous donc il ya des
commerçants sincèrement où les normes
peuvent faire peut être largement
maîtrisé après je sais pas merci en tout
cas bérengère oui vous y croyez peut en
tout cas bon courage à vous merci
d'avoir été avec nos bérengère paitier
godefroy esthéticienne lavaud poudrier
de génie evre merci à vous et malgré un
renforcement du protocole sanitaire non
les lycées pour enrayer l'épidémie de
kobe 19 plusieurs syndicats
d'enseignants ont maintenu leur appel à
la grève aujourd'hui
illustration à lyon où les enseignants
se sont mobilisés pour dénoncer le
manque de moyens accordés au personnel
scolaire face à l'épidémie
reportage signé luis carballo avec
françois xavier lambert
les pancartes appelant à la grève
s'affiche sur les grilles du rectorat de
lyon à l'appel du syndicat force
ouvrière une centaine de professeurs se
sont rassemblés ce matin sous les
fenêtres du recteur de l'académie
tous réclament la mise en place d'un
meilleur protocole sanitaire dans les
établissements scolaires pour ces
enseignants
le gouvernement doit accélérer le
recrutement de personnel éducatif
la meilleure façon de protéger les
enseignants et les élèves
c'est de recruter massivement des
enseignants tout de suite pour alléger
les classes et pour que les collègues
absents soit remplacé il ya plein
d'enseignants qui sont sur liste
complémentaire des concours
il ne tient qu'au recteur de les
recruter dès maintenant il nous faut
donc plus d'enseignants pour assurer les
conditions de sécurité dans les écoles
et dans les établissements
les manifestants dénoncent aussi les
mauvaises conditions de travail
auxquelles ils font face au quotidien
depuis la rentrée notamment le manque d'
espaces dans les salles de classe et
moyens qu'on a pour mettre en place un
protocole sanitaire sont limités surtout
dans le col de travail parce que c'est
un ancien établissement avec
du coup les problématiques qui sont
récurrentes au vieux bâtiment
des petits espaces notamment dans la
cour et dans l'espace de restauration
pour nous la manière dont protocole
sanitaire mis en place elle passe à 10
selon parmi les autres revendications
force ouvrière demande la distribution
en masse de masques ffp2 ainsi que des
tests de dépistage plus nombreux pour
les personnels des établissements
scolaires une délégation de ces
enseignants a été reçue par le recteur
de lyon pour lui faire part de leurs
demandes
la situation de la crise sanitaire en
espagne et la catalogne qui prend le
contre-pied de la france est misé sur
ces petits commerces la région a pris
des mesures pour favoriser les petites
boutiques par rapport aux grands
magasins les précisions sur place de
leslie singla journaliste indépendante
pendant la seconde vague la catalogne a
pris une batterie de mesures parmi elles
les centres commerciaux ont dû fermer
leurs portes
ainsi que les magasins de plus de 800
mètres carrés alors les grandes
boutiques ont pu rester ouverte mais en
réduisant leur espace à l'intérieur
la catalogne a décidé de favoriser les
petits commerces d'une part pour des
raisons économiques car selon les
associations de commerçants de barcelone
jusqu'à 50% des boutiques pourraient
fermer définitivement leurs portes d'ici
la fin de l'année
d'autre part pour des raisons sanitaires
car la catalogne estime que les mesures
de sécurité sont plus facilement à
contrôlable à l'intérieur des petits
espaces
alors les commerçants ont déjà beaucoup
souffert du premier confinement mais
aussi de la mauvaise saison touristique
à barcelone il salue donc cette mesure
car une nouvelle fermeture aurait été
dramatique pour eux je vous propose de
les écouter
comme on l'a montré il y à toujours plus
de gens qui s'accumulent dans un grand
magasin que dans un petit magasin
et puis quand on donne sur la rue on
peut toujours dire attends un peu avant
d'entrer on peut toujours contrôler
davantage que dans un grand magasin dans
un grand magasin les gens rentrent sans
arrêt et personne ne regarde qui entrent
tous les petits commerces de barcelone
ne sont pas en danger
mais quand même si on se balade dans la
rue on voit que beaucoup ont déjà fermé
beaucoup de locaux à louer mais personne
ne veut le prendre avec la situation
actuelle personne ne prend le risque
donc c'est un cercle vicieux
on verra si on peut l'arrêter
normalement nous les libraires nous
pourrons rester ouvert même s'il ya un
confinement
en principe nous ne serons pas obligés
de fermer mais on n'a pas trop confiance
non plus parce qu'ils ont déjà fait
fermer les cinémas et les théâtres mais
on nous a déclaré comme commerce
essentiel donc tout pourrions toujours
restés ouverts
par ailleurs la mairie de barcelone a
augmenté son budget des illuminations de
noël particulièrement dans les zones
touristiques
l'objectif est à nouveau d'attirer les
barcelonais pour les inciter à consommer
dans les établissements indépendants une
alternative au glyphosate c'est ce que
cherche emmanuel macron qui avait promis
en 2010 est son interdiction pour 2020
précisément ennuyé pour cela il débloque
une enveloppe de 7 millions d'euros
destiné à accélérer les recherches le
ministre de l'agriculture julien de
normandie l'a annoncé il y a quelques
jours emilie gobin avec du lien au prado
le 27 novembre 2017
les états membres de l'union européenne
prolonger l'autorisation du glyphosate
pour cinq ans le même jour
emmanuel macron annoncé sur les réseaux
sociaux que cet herbicide controversées
seraient bientôt interdite en france
j'ai demandé au gouvernement de prendre
les dispositions nécessaires pour que
l'utilisation du glyphosate soit
interdite en france dès que des
alternatives rond été trouvé et au plus
tard dans trois ans promesse non tenue
le glyphosate est toujours utilisé sur
le territoire une demi surprise
puisqu'en janvier 2019 lors d'un débat
citoyen le président de la république
est revenu sur son engagement
je sais qu'il y en a qui voudrait qu'on
interdise tout du jour au lendemain je
vous dis pas faisable et saturé notre
agriculture et même en trois ans on ne
fera pas 100% on n'y arrivera pas je ne
pense pas
autre déclaration en septembre dernier
celle de la ministre de l'ecologie
barbara pompidou elle avait affirmé
vouloir interdire plus de la moitié des
utilisations du glyphosate en france dès
le début de l'année prochaine
une promesse loin des premières
déclarations des manuels macron de son
côté l' agence nationale de sécurité
sanitaire a annoncé le mois dernier des
restrictions d'utilisation
elles entreront en vigueur dans les six
mois avant une interdiction totale
promise pour 2023
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
gilles eric séralini professeur de
biologie moléculaire à l'université de
caen spécialiste des pesticides hauteur
de la ferme pas la lumière des monsanto
peppers aux éditions actes sud
mon soir gilles eric séralini merci
d'être avec nous alors à emmanuel macron
prométhée en novembre 2010 est que le
glyphosate serait interdite nous y
sommes en 2020 et pourtant c'est
toujours pas le cas
la faute à qui à quoi d'abord c'est la
faute aux lobbys qui sont extrêmement
forts qui ont des pressions sur nos
politiques aujourd'hui qu'en français et
allemand pour aider mais hier un
racheter monsanto
les premiers producteurs de glyphosate
au monde et il faut savoir deux choses
d'abord que les alternatives existent
puisque l'agriculture biologique sans
passe et qu'elle n'est pas aidé à la
mesure où l'on pourrait de manière à
développer des alternatives c'est au
glyphosate donc déjà il y à un faux
discours
la deuxième chose c'est que le bonus on
sait très peu que le glyphosate est en
fait mélangé à toute une série de
produits qui sont à base de pétrole
d'arsenic de métaux lourds et que ce
sont eux les vrais toxiques
les formules sommes non déclarées il y a
donc fraudes et des associations
essayent de s'emparer de ce sujet pour
attaquer
non seulement le gouvernement mais les
producteurs
de ces pesticides et aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs a mis sur le marché
toute une série de produits sans
glyphosate mais pour le particulier et
ils contiennent du vinaigre de l'acide
acétique ou des extraits de géraniums
mais nous avons dosé dans une très
récente recherche s'est produit et ils
contiennent énormément de ce qu'on
appelle les hydrocarbures polycycliques
aromatiques
quand on trouve aussi dans les gaz de
voitures ou qu'on trouve dans les
dérivés du pétrole et ils contiennent
énormément de métaux lourds dont
l'arsenic
c'est à dire que les procédés pour
fabriquer le glyphosate ou des
pesticides en général sont extrêmement
dommageable pour l'environnement
ce n'est donc pas seulement du
glyphosate dont il faut se passer mais
de l'ensemble des pesticides et les
méthodes existent déjà
il faut stimuler l'agriculture
écologique ou l'agro écologie ou
l'agriculture biologique alors en 2019
emmanuel macron avait déjà tempéré un
peu sa promesse en et santé qu'il allait
certainement pas y arriver en disant
qu'une interdiction du jour au lendemain
en gros tu re et notre agriculture est
ce que vous y croyez à cette version où
il a peut-être aussi peur de se mettre
les agriculteurs à dos qui constitue une
énorme économie en france évidemment
alors je ne sais pas si ça constitue une
énorme économie en fait ça nous coûte
très très cher puisque la politique
agricole commune qui subventionne cette
agriculture intensive et le premier
budget de l'europe qui est évidemment
alimenté par tous les pays dont la
france et l'allemagne
donc nous payons très cher cette
agriculture intensive et je pense que
manuel macro on savait dès le départ
qu'il ne voulait pas sortir de
l'agriculture intensive parce que les
lobbyistes justement sont extrêmement
forts cet argent qui vient donc des
impôts et bien sert à alimenter la
politique agricole commune qui va au
plus gros agriculteurs qui eux mêmes
avec cet argent rachète des pesticides
donc c'est un serpent vicieux qui se
mord la queue et qui nous coûte très
très cher au niveau de la santé au
niveau
la pollution au niveau 2 du climat parce
que l'agriculture selon le giec est bien
représenté au moins 30 % des causes et
dérèglement climatique
alors il ya quand même 7 millions
d'euros qui sont destinés à la recherche
pour trouver des alternatives au kilo
vif aux autres qui vont être investis à
annonces du ministre de l'agriculture
quoi c'est pour la communication enfin
on imagine quand même que ça correspond
à une volonté réelle d'en changer de la
communication parce que c'est une toute
petite soeur et que les alternatives je
vous le dis existe déjà avec
l'agriculture biologique ou la loi
écologie ou la permaculture
il a été montré par des rapports de la
fao internationaux que l'on pouvait
nourrir 12 milliards d'hommes avec la
gouaille écologie sur terre ce n'est
donc pas un problème en fait
l'agriculture intensive sert surtout à
nourrir les cochons les vaches et je les
poulets qui sont un camp de
concentration
et c'est justement ce dont on ne veut
plus on veut de la bonne viande dans des
fermes ouvertes et c'est de ce système
qu'il faut changer
on n'a pas besoin de faire des
recherches technologiques pour continuer
à faire de l'agriculture intensive on
doit simplement changer de méthode et ça
on connaît toutes les manières de le
faire mais ça implique évidemment de
changer la politique agricole commune
est de - financer les grands groupes
dont emmanuel macron départ lui-même
pour sa réélection
alors on nous promet quand même le
changement en 2023 effectivement ça sera
après l'élection présidentielle
vous y croiserez croyez-vous à cette
interdiction totale du glyphosate en
2023 si ce sont les mêmes qui sont au
pouvoir en 2023 ils vont dire en 2025
ils vont continuer comme ça à nourrir m
est non je ne pense que réellement nous
avons non seulement tout
les alternatives mais en plus
aujourd'hui vous savez demandé à vivre
j'ai montré dans l'émotion toppers que
monsanto et bayer sarret et nous en
avons les preuves c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que les avocats américains
ont gagné contre monsanto
il savait qu'il commercialisait des
produits toxiques notamment avec tous
ses produits ses poisons qui sont en
plus de befoza qui ne sont pas déclarés
dans la bouteille donc nous avons
aujourd'hui toutes les preuves
simplement c'est un système qui est au
pouvoir et qui continue à s'auto
alimenter merci beaucoup
gilles eric séralini professeur de
biologie moléculaire à l'université de
caen spécialiste des pesticides merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france dans quelques instants rester
avec nous nous partirons dans le haut
karabagh ou un accord de cessez le feu a
été trouvé entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan comme l'a confirmé hier
soir vladimir poutine et puis nous
évoquerons le mini sommet européen
contre le terrorisme et mène le maître
on recevait aujourd'hui à l'élysée
sebastian kurz chancelier autrichien
le président français appelle à une
réponse rapide et coordonnée
[Musique]
l'euro numérique à nous dit la bce
existerait donc parallèlement aux
espèces sans les remplacer
évidemment ils avancent masqués ils vont
pas vous dire dès le départ on fait ça
pour supprimer le yach l'abonné c'est
déjà numérique du temps que ces
numérique
c'est clair que le papier-monnaie france
est condamnée à terme
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que fait la banque
centrale elle récupère le système
technologique et elle se l'approprient
si vous avez le patrimoine aujourd'hui
vous regardez avec l'anxiété votre
portefeuille tous les matins c'est pas
du tout cas pour votre compte en banque
ont moqué sur votre bande ka
traditionnel ça s'inscrit dans un
mouvement qui est là depuis déjà
plusieurs années qui est d'avoir le plus
de renseignements de ce que vous faites
pour vous utilisez comme un produit
peut-être que c'est le le modèle dont on
rêve
nos dirigeants actuels
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que voilà c'est fini pour moi
est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme sodie mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la réducation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative ressort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inné gilet jaune c'était
des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
à l'époque il y avait une concurrence
qui était assez violente d'ailleurs
entre les russes et les américains alors
que j'étais destinée à voler avec les
russes mais une opportunité s'est
ouverte de faire partie du deuxième
groupe d'astronautes européens qui m'a
envoyé aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa m'a entraîné qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs
on est loin de la guerre des étoiles la
en est quand même dans une espèce de con
fraternité et de solidarité
l'exploration au sens large est une
activité en coopération internationale
où on se rend service entre nations qui
pourtant au même moment son sujet
d'embargo et de conflits géopolitiques
savoir est ce que l'homme peut vivre et
travailler dans l'espace est ce qu'il
existe de la vie ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout sans le fait en coopération
internationale malgré des tensions
à la surface de nos terres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment on peut expliquer qu'elle un
groupe énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables ce n'est pas explicable
mais ça permet d'envoyer aussi des
gratifications on va dire à des à des
politiciens nigérien la gestion
fantaisiste d'areva a des répercussions
incroyable jusqu'au président américain
obama donne son accord pour qu'areva
bénéficie d'un prêt de 2 milliards de
dollars alors que l'agent ce qui est
censé gérer ces prêts un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle crée un
incident
c'est pour l'éternité
[Musique]
21h30 heure française bienvenue sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez ankara
contrôlera avec moscou l'application du
cessez-le-feu dans le haut-karabagh la
nuit dernière le président russe
vladimir poutine a confirmé la signature
d'un accord sur un arrêt total des
hostilités dans cette région
cette annonce fait suite à six semaines
de combats intenses entre erevan et
bakou
mais entre les deux camps les tensions
restent malgré tout très vive solène
vaudin un accord de paix pour le haut
karabagh régions disputées entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan est un cessez
le feu sous l'égide de la russie et de
la turquie vadier juste j'espère que tu
y joueras signer nous avons prises les
mèneront à une paix à long terme au
profit des peuples azerbaïdjanais et
arménien cette fin des hostilités
intervient après plusieurs trêve
humanitaire sans succès et 44 jours de
guerre pour assurer la paix 2000 soldats
russes sont déployés dans la région
depuis son art dit de son côté
l'azerbaïdjan se réjouit de cette
décision perçue comme une capitulation
de l'arménie selon les propres termes du
président ilham aliev
[Applaudissements]
je tiens à dire que je suis très heureux
aujourd'hui marque la fin du conflit à
long terme entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan et marque la fin de
l'occupation des terres azerbaïdjanaises
avec cet accord les azéris reprennent la
ville historique de shoushi point
stratégique entre la capitale de
l'enclavé stepan à cayres et l'arménie
la turquie alliée de l'azerbaïdjan se
félicite elle aussi de la situation
[Musique]
la question à l'arménie était celle qui
a toujours pu le cessez le feu à balles
arménie était celle qui voulait que la
guerre et les combats se poursuivent
l'arménie a payé un lourd tribut après
cela mais ce compromis laisse un goût
amer à l'arménie c'est une décision
incroyablement douloureuses pour moi et
pour notre peuple
la décision est basée sur des analyses
approfondies de la situation au front et
des discussions avec des experts
cela n'est pas une victoire mais il n'y
a pas de défaite
tant que l'on ne se considère pas soi
même battu cela doit marquer le début
d'une nouvelle ère pour notre unité
nationale
l'annnonce de cet accord de paix a
déclenché une vague de manifestations à
erevan la capitale arménienne depuis
hier des milliers de personnes
protestent devant le siège du
gouvernement
ils réclament la démission du premier
ministre arménien nikol pashinian un
cessez le feu fragile donc et qui
pourrait amorcer une crise politique en
arménie alors avec cet accord la guerre
est-elle vraiment terminée la paix est
elle possible entre ces deux camps qui
où les tensions pardon sont extrêmement
vives c'est l'objet de notre face à face
ce soit
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
franck papazian co président du conseil
de coordination des organisations
arméniennes de france bon soit franck
papazian merci d'être avec nous pour
débattre jérôme lambert vice président
du groupe d'amitié parlementaire france
azerbaïdjan bonsoir avoue jérôme lambert
merci d'être là également on a vu la
réaction arménienne après la
confirmation du cessez le feu une foule
en colère qui a envahi le siège du
gouvernement arménien hier soir on parle
de souffrance de goût amer est ce que
ces arméniens vont accepter ce cessez le
feu selon vous franck papazian
nous attendons ce cessez le feu ou
plutôt l'arrêt déclaré l'arrêt de
l'arrêt forcé effectivement de cette
résistance des arméniens contre
l'azerbaïdjan soutenu par la turquie et
les ja liste comme une véritable
injustice
le laser vert jean a entamé une guerre
violente avec beaucoup de moyens contre
les arméniens du haut-karabakh et
l'arménie le 27 septembre dernier
ils ont été soutenus parce que les
milliards de dollars d'armements qui ont
été accumulées depuis plus de 25 ans par
laser belge en et n'était pas suffisant
ils ont appelé au secours
la turquie deuxième puissance de l'otan
qui elle même a appelé au secours 2010 à
10 des terroristes qui sont venus de
syrie pour faire la guerre à l'arménie
aux arméniens du haut-karabakh pour
mettre la main sur ce territoire
arménien depuis des millénaires et qui a
été attribué par staline à l'azerbaïdjan
en 1921 et donc nous considérons
effectivement que cette victoire de
l'azerbaïdjan de la turquie des
terroristes djihadistes donc de deux
dictatures contre la démocratie
arménienne laisse un goût amer
c'est une victoire injuste le monde
entier regrettera en fait d'avoir laissé
faire en 2020 ce qui l'a blessé père en
1915 parce que si effectivement les
combats se continuaient
et bien nous aurions pu assister à de
nouveaux massacres
des arméniens en 2020 alors l'histoire
n'est pas que ni les rapports de force
évoluent ces territoires sont arméniens
et ils redeviendront un jour parce que
nous sommes conscients et nous sommes
convaincus que un jour effectivement le
monde rendra justice et reconnaîtra son
énorme son nom son erreur pardon jérôme
lambert vous comprenez ces propos on
sent quand même effectivement il ne s'en
cache pas les arméniens y parle de
souffrance un aujourd'hui vous comprenez
les propos de franck papazian
je peux comprendre l'émotion de nos
compatriotes français qui pour autant d
origine arménienne
mais c'est vrai que nous sommes au
lendemain d'un accord nous sommes au
lendemain d'un changement profond pour
cette région la restitution des
territoires que l'arménie elle même
avait conquis 1 dans les débuts des
années 90 le haut karabagh faisant
partie de ces territoires mais du haut
karabagh me représentant finalement que
une part très minoritaire des
territoires conquis deux entre 90 et 93
donc nous sommes au lendemain de cet
accord c'est vrai que compte tenu de la
propagande qui avait été conduite mais
la propagande il y en a toujours dans
les deux tombent tous les camps qui
disait que les forces qui défend des ces
territoires étaient en passe de
l'emporter
évidemment je comprends le choc que
finalement d'une certaine façon
l'arrêt des combats et la reddition et
finalement le retour des territoires à
l'azerbaïdjan je comprends que ce que ce
choc soit assez profond de ce qu'il a dû
surprendre donc plus d'arméniens qui
croyaient en la parole de leur
gouvernement
mais finalement que doit-on tirer tout
ça il ya eu 93 des résolutions du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu qui ont
clairement dit qu'elle était le droit en
vigueur qui ont clairement dit à qui
appartenaient ces territoires conquis
par l'armée
la résolution 884 en particulier qui
cite le haut karabagh bien aujourd'hui
depuis 25 ans plus exactement le groupe
de minsk dont chacun dû entendre parler
avait pour mission de trouver des
conditions de l'application de la
résolution de l'onu mais depuis 25 ans
malheureusement parce que tout aurait
été différent si ça avait été possible
eh bien depuis 25 ans lui la paix n'a
pas fait du tout progrès parce que les
négociations n'ont absolument pas
avancer alors moi déjà deux reprises en
et cet été en 2020 j'avais écrit aux
différents présidents de la république
françois hollande lui et emmanuel macron
pour leur signifier que la situation
commençait à être problématique puisque
le peuple azerbaïdjanais ses dirigeants
et de ton plaisir budget n'est attendez
attendez à ce que le droit international
soit appliqué
il est arrivé cet été maintenant que
exactement il est arrivé que ben les
armes mouvement à nouveau parler et
finalement heureusement aujourd'hui et
cette salle dont on doit se réjouir la
paix reggae elle vaut haïti conclu
faut-il que cette paix effectivement
maintenant puisse se réaliser dans de
bonnes conditions
oui on va y revenir on va laisser la
parole à franck papazian cet accord sous
l'égide de la russie
jérôme lambert faisait allusion au
groupe de minsk clairement franck
papazian c'est un échec aujourd'hui du
travail effectué par le groupe de minsk
injuste c'est une péninsule le valide le
tracé des frontières et un p 1 et donc
gratuitement le droit à l'eau pose
question de l'intangibilité des 15
derniers frontière établie par staline
en 1921
outre le droit à l'autodétermination 10e
qui est un concept de gauche au camp de
monsieur lambert devrait plutôt
consacrer le la question du droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes puisque
je pense qu'ils les socialistes stage
alors que la question de l'intangibilité
des frontières tracées barça ni sincère
man j'aurai un peu honte de défendre sa
part un pont un don de défendre ça
j'aurai un plant également de défendre
l'azerbaïdjan est une dictature farouche
qui est 168ème sur 180 dans le
classement mondial de la liberté de la
presse et qui aujourd'hui un état
corrompu qui est un état guerrier est un
état qui a accumulé l'armement militaire
depuis 20 ans 25 ans et monsieur alief
le président de la république de la
servette gens que vous rejoignez
visiblement demain monsieur lambert
puisque vous allez à bas coût de main a
dit
j'avais dit qu'on chasserait les
arméniens de notaire comme des chiens et
nous l'avons fait est ce que monsieur
lambert vous cautionnez ses propos du
président de la république d'azerbaïdjan
jérôme lambert votre réponse moi je
regrette les paroles qui sont prononcés
ce soin n'est pas seulement ce soin je
suis attentif à tout ce qui se dit
depuis la signature de cet accord et je
constate que malgré tout surtout en
france d'ailleurs surtout en france bien
sûr quelques centaines aussi de
manifestants à erevan mais surtout en
france des français
finalement continue la propagande comme
si finalement la guerre ne devait pas
cesser la guerre à cesser la guerre a
cessé le droit international et est
revenu alors maintenant que ce soit le
tel ou tel régime dans tel ou tel pays
vous savez le droit international
à partir du moment où le conseil de
sécurité 10 avec l'accord de la france
d'ailleurs dit ces territoires
appartiennent à l'azerbaïdjan ils
appartiennent en azerbaïdjan c'est pas
staline qui a décidé sans c'est le
conseil de sécurité des nations unies et
voilà donc c'est le droit international
moderne qui résulte des décisions prises
aujourd'hui par le conseil de sécurité
de l'onu qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
je vous réponde à ça c
c'est la réalité tout simplement la
radio ouï oui votre wii alliés est-ce
que vous cautionnez des groupes aux
dahlias ce n'est demain à coup qui a dit
j'avais dit qu'on chasserait les amis un
de nos terres comme des chiens et nous
l'avons pèse que vous cautionnez ça
monsieur lambert j'ai pas cautionner ou
pas cautionner je suis je j'entends bien
que au lendemain de l'accord beaucoup
d'arméniens comme sans doute beaucoup
d'azerbaïdjanais sont dans une forme je
dirais soit d'extrême déception soit
d'extrême faurie et que j'imagine que
leurs propos je l'espère en tout cas
dépasse en quelque sorte leur pensée il
faut maintenant travailler à la paix et
c'est pas avec de tels discours qu'on va
y arriver
ni les vôtres ni ce que je peux entendre
aussi de lapins de quelques
azerbaïdjanais dont monsieur livre ce
que j'étais surpris qu'ils qui
considèrent les arméniens comme des
chiens c'est pas d'ailleurs
l'explication c'est que c'est pas les
arméniens mais c'est les troupes
arméniennes qui occupent le territoire
azerbaïdjanais mais enfin peu importe
peu importe je n'aime pas entendre
simple mais aujourd'hui la question
n'est pas là la question c'est est ce
qu'on veut la paix ou pas rappelons
justement ce que vous voulez de la paix
aujourd'hui malgré la déception et
l'amertume clairement nous voulons il
rompait sur les territoires les
arméniens arméniens d'arménie grimpait
sur les territoires ils sont les leurs
c'est la paix qui a été imposée la force
des canons et à puissance militaire de
l'azerbaïdjan est de la turquie est une
belle juste ces territoires
appartiennent aux arméniens depuis des
millénaires ils sont volés aujourd'hui
par l'azerbaïdjan et la turquie et les
djihadistes on doit condamner ça on ne
peut pas accepter effectivement ça quand
vous parlez nous droit international la
france dit se tenir hors des d'arménie
halak
elle a renouvelé son amitié elle a tout
de même comme l'a dit jérôme lambert a
prouvé ces événements finalement vous
sentez abandonné aujourd'hui par par la
france ou ou pas sa surface
permettez moi c'était une caisse noire
afin de papaye et les moyens je sais me
mettais beaucoup pour partir sur une
base plus clair nous sommes d'accord
mais rien de déterminé de décider quelle
terre leur appartient
parce qu'après tout - d'après gala des
arméniens en iran des des arméniens en
russie il ya des arméniens en turquie il
ya des arméniens des millions
d'arméniens autour de l'arménie et
toutes ces terres là ou alors j'y
comprends plus rien je n'approuve pas ce
discours toutes ces terrains-là
n'appartiennent pas à l'arménie ce sont
des traités internationaux
ce sont surtout des décisions du conseil
de sécurité de l'onu qui fixe le droit
donc le droit à rixheim la france en
matière la simple volonté de dire cette
semaine les l'histoire et les frontières
effectivement est allé on peut pas
régler en 10 minutes le fond de votre
problème qui qui qui qui semble perdurer
en tout cas aujourd'hui vous vous sentez
soutenu tout simplement vous seul nous
pensons que la coupe est international a
commis une grave erreur qu'elle
regrettera
elle se rendra compte dans quelques
années monsieur lambersart raconte
lui-même aussi je pense que donc ils les
choses peuvent changer peuvent continuer
à évoluer parce que les rapports de
force évoluent et nous les arméniens ne
renoncerons jamais à ces taxes en
arménienne allez-y monsieur lambert dans
le haut-karabakh nous verrez les
centaines d'églises ou verrez les
monastères vous verrez effectivement
tous les lieux de vie en fait ils ont
animé l'histoire de l'arménie durant des
millénaires
allez-y et peut-être que vous reviendrez
en ayant changé d'avis parce
qu'aujourd'hui on appelle nous assistons
à la prise en otage des arméniens haut
karabakh qui ne peuvent pas vivre à
portée de canon en fait de l'azerbaïdjan
puisse que l'azerbaïdjan a massacré les
arméniens durant des dizaines d'années
et puis également là
les années 80 et au début des années 90
l'azerbaïdjan a imposé hier à l'arménie
que l'arménie a gagné en 1994 et depuis
1994 elle a violé nous parler du droit
international l'azerbaïdjan a violé le
cessez le feu entre 6000 et 10 mille
fois par an alors c'est inacceptable ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui est
inacceptable c'est injuste la communauté
internationale s'est trompée elle a cédé
à la force des canons et des
pétrodollars de l'azerbaïdjan soutenu
par la turquie
c'est pas correct ce n'est pas bhl merci
à tous les deux ans prend 1 vous me
croirez n'y a pas eu d'accord avec eux
la propagande continue il faut faire la
pub maintenant c'était effectivement
dans ce que j'ai de notre débat initial
la paix peut-elle à bas coût de même
monsieur lambert vous partez plein en
azerbaïdjan pour fêter la victoire de
l'azerbaïdjan bravo merci à tous les
deux en tout cas franck papazian et
jérôme lambert d'avoir accepté ce débat
merci à vous deux emmanuel macron a reçu
à l'elysée le chancelier autrichien
aujourd'hui dont le pays a été frappé
par le terrorisme récemment une entrevue
suivie d'un mini sommet virtuel avec
notamment guélat merkel et le président
du conseil européen charles michel qui
s'est déjà entretenu hier avec sebastian
course les deux hommes une coopération
continental un nouveau rendez vous est
prévu en décembre
toutes nos capitales nous tous qui
sommes ici réunis ont été touchés et le
terrorisme de paris à bruxelles en
passant par berlin vienne utrecht
londres madrid barcelone copenhague
stockholm nice viennent maintenant et
tant d'autres est une réalité européenne
à laquelle nous devons apporter une
réponse
c'est pourquoi nous avons besoin d'une
réponse commune coordonnée et rapide
c'est ce que nous avons acté aujourd'hui
s'ensuivra un travail méthodique dans
les prochaines semaines et un premier
rendez vous avec l'ensemble de nos
collègues lors du conseil de décembre ce
sont des bombes à retardement et si nous
voulons protéger tout notre liberté nous
vont restreindre la liberté de ces
personnes je pense que nous devons
adopter une approche plus solide face
aux menaces qui pèsent sur l'europe car
ces terroristes n'ont pas de frontières
et où qu'il soit en europe
il constitue une menace pour nous tous
pedro fuenzalida inch hayden est selon
moi le facteur décisif
outre la coopération des services
secrets sera également que la police ait
davantage de possibilités de faire face
aux menaces apparente
nous avons des milliers de combattants
terroristes étrangers dans lieux dont
certains sont toujours en prison mais
dont beaucoup sont maintenant liberté où
sortiront bientôt de prison place oui
pour en parler non seulement avec gilles
sacaze anciens cadres du service action
de la dgse
bonsoir gilles sacaze merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt fronce les
européens qui disent avoir besoin d'une
réponse coordonnée et rapide c'est ce
qu'a déclaré emmanuel macron mentionnant
le développement de bases de données
commune des échanges d'informations ou
le renforcement des politiques pénales
alors tout cela a l'air bien au général
des déclarations de bons sentiments on
se demande aujourd'hui ça n'a pas été
fait déjà avant quand même tout ça si la
coopération si vous voulez entre les
différents pays européens existent en
matière de renseignement et même en
matière de police plus opérationnelles
bien sûr qu'elle existe qu'elle soit pas
homogène entre les différents membres de
l'union européenne c'est certain qu'ils
aient les quais de grosse voix je dirais
de d'amélioration pour homogénéiser tout
ça est amené tout le monde sur des modes
opératoires et des et des politiques
communes bien sûr qu'il ya un chantier
qu'il faut que la réponse est soit comme
une commune coordonnée et rapide
si ces jalons sont tenus je dirais que
c'est effectivement bien mais on est on
est habitué du télé et à des discours
d'intention qui sont rarement suivies
d'effets alors c'est vrai que
l'actualité un peu contraint tout le
monde les peuples aujourd'hui avec l'âme
de passer du discours à l'action il
semblerait que ceux ci étaient entendus
par pas par nos dirigeants européens
mais pour l'instant on est on est dans
l'intention donc il faudra voir les
semaines à venir
mais c'est bien le problème gilles
sacaze c'était ma première question
n'est dans l'intention d'en face où on
se souvient parfaitement de ses discours
ont lendemain des attaques terribles qui
avait frappé la france ont en 2015 on
parlait déjà ce fameux pnr le passenger
name code
apparemment c'est un dispositif qui a
été mis en place mais pas achevé c'est
vrai qu'on peut se poser la question
décemment pourquoi est ce si compliqué
de se mettre d'accord en europe
oui il ya eu çà vous avez raison il ya
eu également frontex je veux dire qui et
qui était un immense échec je dirais je
suis un peu dur dans peut-être dans mon
jugement mais aujourd'hui on dépense de
l'argent pour frontex et puis on finance
également des associations qui
travaillent à des tours à contourner
frontex donc il ya un manque
complètement de cohérence on se souvient
aussi de la période si vous voulez où on
a cloué au pilori la pologne la hongrie
l'autriche parce qu'on trouvait qu'ils
avaient une politique de contrôle de
l'immigration qui correspondaient pas
aux normes européennes si aujourd'hui on
se rapproche un petit et politique là
pour pour enfin protéger nos frontières
le président l'a dit encore une fois le
discours était parfait quand le
président nous a dit aujourd'hui que
schengen c'était
l'abandon en gros pour faire rapide mais
l'abandon de nous de nos frontières
nationales au profit de frontière en
plein et de contrôle sur nos frontières
européennes et que et que cette promesse
n'avait pas été tenus et que aujourd'hui
on remettait en question schengen
alléluia jusqu'à présent tous ceux qui
qui remettait en question qui avait le
malheur de remettre en question le
schengen et étaient considérés comme des
réactionnaires insupportable et est
menacé même d'exclusion de l'union
européenne il faut s'en souvenir
ça veut dire que soudainement devient
souverainistes à deux ans de l'élection
présidentielle où c'est une nécessité il
ya selon vous une vraie intention une
vraie volonté est là dedans il ya une
vraie on peut pas faire de procès
d'intention un cidre et connaît on a été
tellement déçus par des discours un
petit peu guerrier suivi de rien du tout
que on est en droit aujourd'hui il est
parfaitement légitime de se poser la
question mais je crois qu'il ya une
exigence aujourd'hui on voit la classe
politique française par exemple ces
postures là elle était plutôt à droite
de l'échiquier politique en france
je de jeu les postures de contrôle de
l'immigration de contrôle aujourd'hui le
lien par exemple entre l'immigration et
le terrorisme effet sur les plateaux
télé papa par toute la classe politique
quasi toute la classe politique j'ai
goûté julien dray pour ne pas le nommer
la semaine dernière qui faisait ce lien
sans aucun complexe et si vous voulez ça
c'est une vraie évolution et je dirais
que si en france en tout cas après je
sais pas si on sera suivie au lieu de
rentrer mais on a on a dit on a des
alliés encore une fois les pays qu'on a
critiqués pour avoir ces postures là il
ya quelques temps si aujourd'hui on fait
au moins quinze communes avec un certain
nombre de pays européens peut-être que
les choses peuvent bouger en tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est qu'à une vraie
exigence aujourd'hui des peuples et pas
qu'en français c'est vrai en italie
c'est vrai en espagne c'est vrai en
allemagne il ya un décalage si vous
voulez entre la posture de nos
dirigeants et les exigences et les
attentes des peuples et que ce qui est
en jeu finalement c'est c'est la
continuité de l'europe
si on construira pas une europe pas sur
le vieux continent on construira une
europe contre les peuples
on ne peut faire illusion quelques temps
mais je pense que la sanction risque
d'être brutal
on l'a vu avec le break site l'aubrac
cité on l'a on n'a jamais été au fond de
l'analyse à savoir pourquoi les anglais
étaient vraiment parce que ça c'était
des sujets tabous mais on pourrait un
jour il faudra bien faire de cette
analyse là et les anglais sont revenus à
une fois à leur souveraineté tout
simplement parce que c'est un peuple un
grand peuple les anglais souverain et
insulaire depuis toute son histoire et
ils sont revenus aux fondamentaux et et
le aujourd'hui c'est le l'enjeu pour
l'europe c'est ça c'est de faire
converger de d'amener les peuples avec
eux autre sujet qui est abordé emmanuel
macron la lutte contre la haine en ligne
c'est un sujet qui regroupe beaucoup de
choses pas seulement le terrorisme parce
que c'est prendre le problème du bon
goût c'est une des composantes je dirais
mais moi ce que je crains si vous voulez
c'est que c'est ce qu'on vit depuis
encore une fois le problème du de
l'islamisme radical de l'islam radical
et de l'islamisme en france et même du
dialyse mais il est révélé depuis 25 ans
depuis râler quelqu'un moi je
chaque fois je rappelle ça parce que je
pense que c'est important ça nous ça
nous empêche de nous des douanes est de
notre responsabilité à faire en tout cas
de nos deux lots de nos dirigeants
chose que je crains s'il voulait avec ce
débat sur tout ce qui est six verres
c'est que comme pour le renseignement
soit toujours à se demander si on peut
pas améliorer les renseignements mme
haigneré l'analyse améliorer la collecte
alors améliorer la lutte contre la haine
en ligne parce que tout ça ce sont des
sujets intellectuelle si vous voulez qui
nous vont bien que en pratique assez
facilement en france mais maintenant on
a besoin d'action si vous leur bien sûr
si on peut lutter contre la haine en
ligne la diffusion aussi que le le le
internet a été un support important sur
la radicalisation ouloto radicalisation
ou là ou l'infirmation d'un certain
nombre d'individus qui sont passés à
l'acte donc on peut pas dire que ce soit
quand le sujet mais encore une fois faut
pas que ça devienne un refuge
intellectuelle pour ne rien faire sur le
plan d'action maintenant ce qu'il faut
c'est passer à l'action et je crois que
les français se hissant attentif et pas
que les français mais les européens en
général ils sont attentistes et il ne
s'en tireront pas encore une fois avec
une pirouette
ou avec un débat intellectuel non plus
finir merci beaucoup gilles sacaze
anciens cadres du service action de la
dgse d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur
rt france et c'est la fin merci à vous
de cette émission se retrouve dans
quelques instants à 22 heures pour un
point complet sur l'actualité du jour
[Musique]
on nous parle de l'afrique comme d'un
continent en perpétuelle de vie sont
dues